[Musique]
je suis venu vous parler principalement
du monument préféré des français qui
revient demain soir sur france 3 et
d'ailleurs nous serons demain soir quel
est le monument que les français ont
choisi il savait depuis le 22 juillet
dernier 1 les votes sont clos depuis 22
juillet oui je le sais je le sais mais
il ya un suspense quand même parce que
parce que j'ai
un manche de guitare de six mètres de
haut à son sommet une harley davidson
bleus ayant appartenu à l'idole la
statue hommage à johnny hallyday a été
dévoilée ce matin devant ses fans si le
symbole est clair certains semblent des
routes est passé le satuc et
moderne c'est au mans c'est moderne moi
je tâchais recontre majeur
en ça je crois
[Musique]
une oeuvre clivante installé désormais
sur l'esplanade johnny hallyday
accompagné de la maire de paris anne
hidalgo laetitia en a elle même dévoilé
la plaque avec ses deux filles jade et
joy très émue elle s'est adressé à la
foule et notamment aux 150 biker
rassemblés pour l'occasion merci d'être
là aujourd'hui c'est un rêve qui devient
réalité
un lieu de rendez vous pour se connecter
à jenny france un homme d'image peut pas
cautionner je trouve ça très moche mais
franchement ronis était un homme aimait
les belles choses et là ça ça lui
ressemble c'est une sombre merde
mais moi je suis fan de johnny je vous
dis la vérité moi je m'en ça on le fait
à temps le haut le 104e de bérets à
l'école sera belle je te promets de ciel
au baiser de ma bouche je te promets de
miel à ma main qui te touche je te
promets le ciel au dessus de ta couche
des fleurs et des dentelles pour que tes
nuits
merci beaucoup et bien s'en passer que
faut-il faire pour devenir célèbre ce
que de la musique est une bonne réponse
déborah
couché
voilà
[Musique]
le numéro 30
originaire
virginie comment ça va ça va mais
j'écris que vous alliez jamais me tirer
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire et
enfin qu'on le connaisse le petit jeu
que le président macron qui auront
passagers est très beau
[Applaudissements]
ça
à bébel un nom mais je reconnais qu'on a
vraiment un très beau président ça peut
le dire s'est jamais arrivé soit ça
casse et unique réponse était pas mais
si
vous mettez en garde le président qui
vous dit en privé tu as raison oui ça
c'est en même temps j'ai l'impression il
me dit parfois oui tu as raison et puis
après je vois là il est obligé d'aller
dans le sens du vent si je puis dire
j'ai péché je le confesse ainsi débute
son grand roman balzacien elle poursuit
péché d'orgueil péché de vanité péché
d'arrogance alors le risque de
l'autoédition c'est qu'il n'ya souvent
personne pour corriger l'orthographe
c'est ainsi qu'on découvre qu eric
zemmour a pêché avec sa canne à pêche
donc au lieu d'écrire gp chez eux accent
aigu son grand livre sur la france
commence donc par une faute de français
est ce que vous le savez bien sûr qu'il
le sait s'il veut être candidat pendant
il le dit il parle pas de ça vainqueur
avec moins de 12 à décortiquer moi bien
sûr
[Applaudissements]
vouloir que quelqu'un qui est né comme
ça et finalement normalement enfin selon
mes principes à moi n'a pas a priori
plus de mérite que d'autres vouloir que
cet homme devienne providentiel comme sa
part par l'opération visait quatre
villes anciennes il est l'héritier d'une
tradition de service du pays mais qui
sont pas évidentes à la raison je vous
propose de voir le sujet et on écoutera
le président de la ligue de défense
africaine qui était hier soir chez cyril
ou nanak c'est non à la
hauteur j'embrasse pascal chaud
citez-moi des situations dans lesquelles
on crie gabriela quand on s'est fait mal
après les enfants le sexe
[Musique]
je vais pas évident avant jc dernière
image du gala du met une image de ces
dernières heures voilà hier soir à new
york c'était hier soir à new york c'est
la plus grande soirée la mode c'est le
tapis rouge le plus scruté de l'année à
regarder le but c'est de surprendre
choquer d'innover vous la reconnaissez
non kim kardashian et kim kardashian
aurait dû au hasard il peut le
reconnaître là dont les formes que même
alors soit la traversée
en tout cas il ya une volonté de se
cacher ça c'est une certitude c'est
assez pratique en soirée vous savez
qu'on vous croisez les gens voulaient
pas leur parler au moins vous ne
connaissent pas un détail elles des
robes spectaculaires voilà vous
connaissez les chevaliers du zodiaque
oui voilà côté tendances on a eu le col
roulé masquer la robe adada sur mon bide
est le sac à main teckel la tenue
inspiration chapelle sixtine et la tenue
inspiration chapelle fifteen
maison péter un câble les filles à mach
en france
j'ai trouvé c'est superbe cette fille
ressemble vraiment à une poupée une
vraie poupée du moyen-âge commença du
moyen-âge
bakcell et robert un corset comme à les
anciens temps et bien coiffés avec les
anglais et c'était des coiffeurs
fréquentes
j'ai pas d'aimer rafale à tes côtés du
raï cheb être prouvée nous fais moi
mentir moi ça je serai plusieurs du
monde si tu me fait mentir mais moi j'ai
appris sur de fouet preuve c'est que dès
que la pression je fais n'importe quoi
donc je me dis il faut vraiment que
soient concentrés et pour une fois fait
pas de bêtise voilà tu vas y arriver
t'inquiète pas fait pas de gaffe voilà
c'est bon c'est ça va être facile finir
in the night
[Applaudissements]
on va les fumées donnez moi quelque
chose qui se lèchent une glace
un bonbon les fesses
[Rires]
oui c'est beau